today's episode is brought to you by the
US Army
what's that part of people welcome to
honest trailer commentaries where today
we will be talking about the honest
trailer for not Jurassic Park 1 not
Jurassic Park the lost world - but
Jurassic Park no subtitle just number
three baby whoo twice it is weird to
have a series of films that goes from no
number to a number in the middle and
then world and then world yeah there's
been some comments and coulded now we
have 2 : movies one numbered movie
what's stressing Jurassic world 2 is a :
n a number a drastic world know Jurassic
world is just Jurassic world fallen
Kingdom which means that drastic the
next one's gonna be called Jurassic
world 3 if you're following this as the
movies themselves are if you're exactly
following the pattern of the previous
films numbers go out of style because
like transformers are all fancy names
people are less likely to watch a
numbered sequel if they haven't seen the
first one but if it's called Jurassic
Park fallen world Kingdom just show us
up but strangely the numbered sequels of
The Fast and the Furious movies only get
more popular yeah
I'm getting ahead of myself well because
they do the name things Joestar I stay
in Marla we're gonna be talking about
the dress park 3 oz trailer and if you
stick around to the end delayed scenes
do we have any news time so that's that
guys this movie is bad as y'all
remembered it man hot take this is a
dumb bad movie I mean people will defend
it for the fact that it has dinosaurs in
it and I was very persuasive too Dan
yeah I never hated it
it's pretty average it did it's not now
I don't want to re-litigate the same
argument we've had so many times before
yeah but this is a disappointing
Jurassic Park movie yeah it's just
rehashing the things that they've done
over and over again sure why is Jurassic
world so much more upsetting to you than
Dresden than this one it's a good
question I don't know I think this was I
think I think it might be that this one
was obviously running
the fumes of characters and a storyline
that were exhausted already in the last
film and I think that I saw Jurassic
world as a chance to do something really
new and different and exciting and you
kind of were able to reset you can use
new characters and you can really do
just about anything you have a cool set
up you have a cool scenario it is
something where you have a park and you
you can do so many different things and
the fact that I didn't think that
Jurassic world took advantage of that at
all and just did like the laziest most
cliched non exciting things that it
could possibly do I think that might be
like this to me is a franchise that's
just completely out of gas
whereas I thought Jurassic world money
money yeah yeah and I thought jested
world just just had a lot of things
going for it that its squandered in my
eyes fair enough
cuz yet to me I mean I was out from lost
world I truly think that there's only
one good dinosaur theme park gone wrong
story to tell and was it did they manage
to cover it all yeah yeah this one it's
sort of telling as we were trying to
find more ways to say that this is a bad
movie as we were writing this honest
trailer like Michael Crichton and
Spielberg got together to try to figure
out a story and Crichton was like I
don't know man
and he got out and then I think it went
through like four other rides so I think
it's telling when Crichton is just like
we're done here this also was one that I
massively rewritten like very shortly
before they started or even run yeah
even during filming yeah and it really
makes itself clear at the end it's like
the Monty Python ending and then the
Spinosaurus thing you know is always
like you know it comes in and kills the
t-rex and it's like you know yeah I'm
the cool new dinosaur and everybody was
like no I liked the t-rex yeah they also
build in the marketing like fight of the
century Spinosaurus versus t-rex in the
marketing and it was over in ten seconds
you throw this out there I don't think
you can pull off a Spinosaurus because
one no be most people don't
find a source and two dumb name and
looks dumb dumb name yeah dumb looking
stupid dumb name duping mouth shots
fired come you look stupid what are you
even like Tyrannosaurus Rex just not us
where was the Spinosaurus throughout
every event that we'd already see was it
hiding in a corner throughout lost world
it was in the whipped cream can canister
grew out of the ger so many people right
now typing like how dare you Spinosaurus
I'm sure it was written on the container
that Nedry pulled the thing whatever and
the canister was like raptor Spinosaurus
gambit yeah and again this obsession
rears its head again with stealing the
eggs and somebody goes and and takes
tries to take the intellectual property
away from the thing even though of all
people that guy should know better the
guys oh you trying to like sell it so
they could dig more yeah that what he's
trying to do yeah okay I always forget I
forget everything about Billy why is
Billy Billy even yeah okay that's what
he was trying to do yeah cuz it's just
he's just this to me he's always just
the smarmy guy from face off who just
takes a hey college Troy yeah again like
and this is something we point out in
the in the trailers like this film
didn't have a true antagonist it didn't
have engine in it and you know the
dinosaurs are chaotic neutral and it
should have been Billy right now you'd
think it'd be built not to stay on the
Billy Tracey sorry it could be Billy and
then they kind of half-step it with
William H Macy being a fraud and like
the mercenaries are also pretending to
be mercenaries yeah everyone's just it's
a bunch of idiots duping each other onto
an island yeah is a long story of this
yeah it's like a like a Coen Brothers
farce yeah but I think that's what why
we're gonna put my finger on like why I
think the first movies so I love it and
then why I think the movies were
diminishing returns is like the
antagonists in this movie or the
dinosaurs and that that's kind of a
problem that I have with the sequels is
increasingly even in the lost world like
in the first movie the dinosaurs were
threats but the the antagonists are the
closest thing you got to like pure evil
in that movie but there's like Nedry was
an antagonist and it was about survival
and now and especially starting with
this movie and I think in every other
movie they're just monsters yeah they're
just things that jump out of you in the
dark and grab you and they are like
relentless coming after you to you no
matter how far away you get they will
track you and gobble you there murder is
killing machines and part of what made
us apart so great was that it was a
combination of like they're predators
they operate on instinct like they hunt
you but they're not just absolute
monsters you know that there's a there's
a beauty in a wand Wonder mixed in with
their and a respect that starting with
the second one a lot of it and then this
movie and all the subsequent ones
they're just monsters as lizards running
around trying to eat you and I think
that's what they do that obligatory shot
of the nice dinosaurs the herbivores
like grazing and they play the theme
song hey cool like and we put the shot
in there they all go like just like come
in on a weird like just showing off what
they done with rendering technology at
that point like cuz you know things
always look good the year you're
watching it and then you look back and
it looked like a screensaver of like
copy pasted dinosaurs just all out in
the field they all they do now but yeah
you know but even in park later we
should know better
yeah like if if it looks worse than the
third one than they do in the first one
like that's bad yeah not good yeah yeah
it's its economy
shots that they don't let's take out
they didn't shoot anything in the dark
and we'll go backwards to see our honest
trailer for Jurassic Park 3 notice the
motif that the people at this trip they
welcomed you to Jurassic Park
then they welcomed you to the lost world
now the franchise just kind of wears out
its welcome in
Jurassic Park 3 palette before you see v
Jurassic movie
revisit the chapter that made these
movies go extinct for 15 years combining
a rehash pod meaning two islands and
time sword and TV quality effects and to
score the lowest critical response of
the series oh why couldn't Universal of
just listen to Jeff Goldblum
they were so preoccupied with whether or
not they couldn't they didn't stop to
think of a shot so by now you've noticed
that instead of our usual transitions of
just like yeah just the noise and a snap
zoom would you sad to see how many times
you can fit in our favorite clip from
the film everyone's favorite the dream
Raptor saying Alan which I think has
been in every other Jurassic Park
trailer it's the Avenger Circle shot of
the Jurassic franchise this was the
first creative choice we made for this
trailer once we decided this was the
movie work let's see how many times we
can play The Ellen clip yeah now what's
extra funny about this to me is that
this should be a really horrifying flash
of PTSD for this man who's been stalked
by Raptors this is actually like a
really traumatic thing he has nightmares
about yeah Raptors but the nightmares
aren't like he's back in the field where
he's but they're like you know creeping
in a the nightmare is his friend Billy
has her after head he goes bralette
my favorite is the head okay but like
why are the hands like why is the
Raptors been really the Raptors sitting
in the chair just kind of like yeah why
is it just the head why is there after
have to be like no it's up road just
chillin his body working right now where
are the feet is it like when a cat sits
on its haunches or though yeah the legs
legs like splayed out if someone could
find us a full body shot like a pulled
back set photo of that frame right that
is your fan art this is or yeah or draw
what you think is happening
hello the frame yeah a little did they
put feathers yes that's the other thing
is they decided in this movie and only
this movie that the Raptors I guess to
please the scientific community know so
the the paleontologists who was the
advisor on the first one was also the
advisor on this one and at that point
the feather thing had come up and so was
like throwing the feathers and so they
didn't go like full they look like birds
but I think they found a happy design
median and we're like they've got
goatees and cool like warriors gang
facial hair and the drastic world
smartly realized what a dumb idea that
was and yeah and back to the site
I will admit yes probably scientifically
inaccurate but better looking for him
well that also fits though at the park
that they're like we want to create the
dinosaurs that people think they want
and I'm the actual ones because it would
be hilarious but stupid to see a
gigantic t-rex chicken running around as
much as I would love it I don't think
everyone would want to pay to see that
yeah oh there is something kind of neat
about a velociraptor with the mohawk
yeah he's got some food yeah it just
looked odd I think it was an odd look I
respect the I respect the respect that
they had for the scientific community
however I think ultimately in viewing
them both side by side the initial
decision they made cinematically was the
keep it scaly you don't want a raptor
that looks like it's in the mud vein
no but not no one word for that Alan
alright keep playing Indiana Jones - all
charisma it's great thing about bones I
never run away witness the most better
role of his career as he plays a guy
pressured by fans into going back to
Jurassic Park does anyone have a
question that does not relate to
Jurassic Park who finally gives in
because of a paycheck I can write all
your main characters just a grumpy bones
inner part from home they'll be joined
by a cast of new dumb characters like
Billy who carries a parachute on land
for the entire movie just in case this
happens
you know they wrote that sequence first
animation part child of divorce Tay
Leone
yelling you may see as a timid paint
salesman who scams a team of mercenaries
and kidnaps dr. grant to rescue his kid
from the hot shot who's dating his wife
huh I think if they told the story from
his perspective this movie might
actually be good yeah pain that you
brought that up and you're right cuz
then you saw we started talking about
scenes of what it would have looked like
if they had told this move from one
Mitch Macy's point of view and it's kind
of a cool like if you had known when
they're in the place negotiating with
dr. grant that he was in way over his
head I was flying by the seat of his
pants this movie would have been good
time with Dinosaurs yeah that's an
amazing pitch it's very different from
Jurassic Park it is but you got to do
some different characters yeah yeah I
also want to add we have to start a
database of characters saying what
because between that what and then our
Warcraft guy
what what we have to start just keeping
these clips that is a great weaponized
clip for us to just pull out just a Leo
they going what yeah can you play it
again
JT yeah the one of the star yelling what
almost there yeah what what we need a
third one
send us your favorite yeah yes a
favorite what's from film there's also
my other favorite Taleo anything from
this movie is from the premiere cuz it's
just looking around for stuff to add to
the trailer and it's when she was with
David Duchovny and they're at the red
carpet and they're interviewing today
and he's just arm candy and he's just
going doing like a full like Ricky Bobby
I don't know what to do with my hands
and he's very uncommon you send me then
yeah David Duchovny like seven minutes
it's a seven minute interview with Tay
Leone and David company's just awkward
standing the whole time which is great
cuz like he's her date and he has
nothing to do with the movie but like
you can tell he's like kind of listening
kind of getting ready for an x-files
question never comes so David is the
truth really out there it never comes
yeah Jess me about x-files nope okay
yeah fun fact let's keep going this
movie might actually be good this is
t-rex P never mind
Alan do you like dinosaurs well not for
long
cuz this movie ruins every last one of
them killing off the t-rex in seconds
just to show how badass the Spinosaurus
is weirdly obsessing over the Raptors
vocal chords pause and making the
Dodgers Birth shape it's such a weird
hill for grant to die on to be like I
really want to study Raptors I'm really
obsessed with how they communicated and
how they get along but I don't want to
see them in real life I just don't I
mean I guess I get it because he was
traumatized by a more layered to not
like be at least interested it just
didn't it didn't track for me that yeah
I understand him being done with
Dinosaurs completely right with being
that I never want to see another day
still obsessed with it yeah obsessed
with researching and finding out the
truth about him it's very truth is out
there it also never goes anywhere
they're like did you know that Raptors
basically talk to each other like people
they had so much language and blah blah
blah and this and that and here's our
trumpet our dinosaur trumpet and then it
doesn't like they blow on it at the end
and the Raptors kind of react but then
there's immediately helicopters and the
rest it seems to only confuse them yeah
I mean tell me if I'm wrong but I would
also think that if like an alien species
showed up with like a human windpipe and
just blew into it what would be like
what are you blowing into a windpipe
they wouldn't know that's not how that
works
communicated like it's a level of
communication that they show off in the
movie that he's so stunned with is like
he's calling for help like doesn't every
animal like cry
help when it's in trouble yeah that
really like mind blown they do kind of
mean they have scenes where they're like
looking at each other and saying things
but also when I see two dogs barking at
each other I don't assume that they're
having an intelligent I can't just stare
at each other from two feet away all the
time you're right I forgot there are
scenes where the Raptors are going like
and he's like what are you searching
[Laughter]
I have claws do you have claws I ask
food food food have paws food food food
it's all dogs are talking about what's
that trumpet saying yeah anyways let's
keep going and making the dinosaurs
earth-shaking Lee loud but still has
them sneak up on people like Teflon clad
ninjas I'm a stupid
hello hell I also gear up for the most
forgettable Jurassic Park movie that
forgot to include any antagonists forgot
to save any of its budget for an actual
ending the Navy and forgot they put the
phrase my god into the script nine
different times story Allen Tay and the
t-rex crash let me put you on hold over
a minute people tripping all over
themselves on a play
shouting Allen the one where a dinosaur
says maybe we went a little yeah and we
did it again
[Music]
we really went down a a hold there yeah
the Alan's okay whoa what's there left
to say that we didn't say I said Alan I
mean if we're ever gonna reuse that
overuse that clip obviously what are we
gonna retire Alan think it's time I've
done it do it do we'd switch it to what
with the marijuana
that'll be that'll reappear at that
point yeah but Jurassic world fallen to
Kingdom we won't put an Alan in there
unless it's appropriate mm-hmm I having
seen it I don't know if it's wholly
appropriate okay I don't think I'll have
to rewatch with my Alan glasses yeah
we're gonna have to we're gonna put it
in a box break in case of Alan and until
then yes which is a real box in our
writers room yeah put it to rest
yeah the allen wrench doesn't fix
everything so what did we cut from this
honest trailer let's see
score from star mint take it for granted
Lucas he got his grant you gotta take
that board hold o fo Birdemic
[Applause]
and have to be synthetic the dinosaur
story extinction-level event what's that
noise in your movie but if you're gonna
go dumb might as well include an
altering Dino trapper yeah yeah actual
toy you have that job no it's just like
I remembered there being some shitty
Jurassic Park toys what worked better
with the audio because in the audio it's
like look yeah oh yeah look feel like
every movie had a vehicle that shot
something whether that was in the movie
or not all the dinos had Dino damage
yeah and then a the voiceover guy would
say look for the mark of Jurassic Park
cool yeah yeah I had a dad action figure
okay from the first one they were
smaller
they weren't the size of your average
size action figures he come with a
fedora he did attached to his head
attached to his head and I remember
notes no I I think he probably came with
you know they always gave you some kind
of a weapon or something he was in his
movie thickest tomb and I just never I
did a Jurassic Park diorama great and
you had but it had to be based on a book
I based on the book Jurassic Park and I
remember I put I put in marker on his
face a beard because in the book he had
a beard it's a close reading action
figure but I genuine a beard I think it
might still have that beard I think it's
long gone I probably did I don't know
the best thing about all the Jurassic
Park toys was all the main characters
are nerds are scientists and doctors and
so it's like hang glide action dr.
Malcolm that's what they're trying to do
with Billy is like let's get like an
extreme sports paleontologist yeah like
if you've seen the Jeff Goldblum his
excavator drastic park was Jeff Goldblum
yeah its action figure for Independence
Day was a whole Cogan action yeah Jeff
Goldblum head he's like got a massive
barrel chest and it's like I used to be
on the set I don't know if it's over
there anymore but yeah it was pretty
it's insane what they convinced back in
the 90s for every movement finally yeah
that's somewhere over there what's that
franchise with like dinosaurs but they
like shoot missiles off their backs and
I know writers Dino riders yeah oh that
movie right
I feel like Jurassic world that's slow
coming it yeah yeah get that yeah I
think we might have got a good point
yeah yeah yeah well I think that's all
the brainpower worth wasting on Jurassic
Park 3 don't you think Alan Alan and
with that we give you a resounding Alan
and a tease for next week's honest
trailer which is well I mean some
difference yeah a two-for-one a
two-for-one yeah yeah a double feature
yeah exactly
so we hope you enjoy it and if not you
can tell us all about it next week here
on honest trailer commentaries see ya
today's episode was brought to you by
the u.s. army find out more by clicking
the link below
[Music]
you